tg un mot puisque jean-pierre est ici
présents député du loiret qui est
secrétaire nationale à la santé avec
valérie boyer sachez qu'on est en train
de préparer une alternative à cette fois
santé de marisol touraine sur laquelle
on a beaucoup bataillé les uns et les
autres et donc raison de plus pour vous
puisqu'elle est en élaboration on
présentera une proposition de loi à
l'assemblée nationale est donc alimenté
cette proposition de loi
vous avez vos interlocuteurs n'hésitez
surtout pas c'est à partir des exemples
que vous n'êtes données très
concrètement ce qu'on apportait
d'ailleurs dans l'hémicycle mais qu on
déposera cette proposition de loi de
même qu'on l'a fait sur l'agriculture
avec une proposition de loi alternative
c'est comme ça aussi que les
républicains travaillent
sachez qu'il ya des députés et des
sénateurs il faut absolument nous
utiliser pour ça